hello and welcome to the Monte Carlo
simulation experiment with Python poor
we began we should establish what a
Monte Carlo simulation is the idea of a
Monte Carlo simulation is to test
various outcome possibilities so in
reality only one of the outcome
possibilities will actually play out but
in terms of risk assessment any of the
possibilities could have occurred and
therefore should should be weighed in to
whether or not a decision was a good one
so Monte Carlo simulators are often used
to assess risk of a given say trading
strategy with options or stocks Monte
Carlo simulators can help drive the
point home that success is success is
not the only measure of whether a choice
was good or not
choices should not be assessed after
their outcome instead the risks and
benefits should only be considered at
the time the decision was made so the
whole hindsight bias you know we have a
human's just in general are very good at
fitting you know reasoning to why
something might have occurred after the
fact but we're pretty bad at it before
the before the fact so a Monte Carlo
simulator can help help someone
visualize most or all in some scenarios
of the potential outcomes to have a much
better idea regarding the risk of a
decision so with that let's consider in
this video in the next few videos a
really basic example so here we're gonna
consider a gambling scenario where a
user can role quote unquote a
metaphorical dice for an outcome of
something like 1 to 100 if the user
rolls anything from a 1 to a 50 the
quote unquote house wins if the user
rolls anything from a 51 to a 99 the
quote unquote user wins if the user
rolls a 100 they lose so with this the
house maintains a mere 1% edge which is
markedly lower than the
in most situations where you have
speculation or gambling taking place so
for example consider if you're trading
with say Scottrade where the
metaphorical house is taking seven
dollars a trade if you invest a thousand
dollars per stock this means you have to
pay seven dollars in entry and seven
dollars an exit for a total of fourteen
dollars so this puts your your the
metaphorical house edge 21.4%
notably though Scottrade is not the
actual house right so when you lose you
don't pay Scottrade right you just pay
them the fee so the house is basically
everyone except for you so this means
that on the long term scale your bets or
your your your speculation and stocks
need to do better than 1.4 percent
profit need to be better 1.4 percent
profit on average than your losses right
otherwise you will be losing money so
despite the fact that that's a very
small number
the odds are already against you and as
you'll see very quickly even with such a
small percentage odds against you like
in our case we're gonna use one percent
the more wagers or the more stocks you
purchase in this example the less likely
your life are the less likely you are to
have a long life expectancy here I
expect a lot of people would make
arguments regarding my house odds
assessment with Scottrade in stocks and
all that so let's go ahead and just
stick with dice with a hundred sides for
now very simple so a Monte Carlo
generator can also help illustrate the
flaws of the gamblers fallacy so many
gamblers even and sometimes especially
gamblers who understand statistics fall
prey to the gamblers fallacy
so the fallacy asserts that taking
something like flipping like the
flipping of a coin for heads or tails
you have a known 50/50 odds that said if
you just flipped heads five times in a
row somehow you're more likely to flip
tails next no matter how many times
heads have proceeded
your odds each time you flip the coin or
always 50/50 so it's easy to fall into
the trap of thinking that on the
long-term scale odds will kind of be
drawn to this 50/50
therefore if odds are currently
imbalanced then the next flips odds are
also not 50/50 because they must you
know seek this 50/50 equilibrium that's
not true it's every flip seeks this
50/50 equilibrium and as well as we'll
find with the scenario that we're going
to do now it is simply not the case that
just because you know something occurs
you know a bunch of times even with
50/50 odds it does not mean that the
next thing will be yeah the opposite so
again with our example in mind just
remember of the big user roles 1/2 a 50
the house wins 50 1 to 99 the user wins
and a perfect 100 means the house wins
so let's go ahead and begin so first we
have to generate our actual dies and for
this we're gonna first can employ the
pseudo-random number generator within
Python so let's go ahead and get started
so we're gonna import
that's odd there we go
import random and now we're going to
define roll dice no parameters for this
and we're just going to say role equals
random dot R and int so this is just a
random integer between 1 and 100 and
that's it so then at the end of this
we'll return the roll and that's it for
now so now let's go ahead and just
quickly test our dice to make sure it's
giving us what we want so we're just
gonna say x equals 0 while X is less
than 100 results equals roll dice print
results and then X plus equals 1 sounds
good
we'll save and run this and sure enough
here is our output
here so here's obviously a one and then
a bunch of numbers I don't see a 100 but
it was possible we just didn't get one
so now that we have a dice done what we
want now is we need a better so we need
to make just a simple better in our
program so that's what we're going to be
doing in the next video is creating our
better
who's going to bet on this dice roll so
anyway stay tuned to the next video as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time